the death toll is still rising from
Northern California's massive wildfires
41 people are confirmed dead they range
in age from 14 to 100 among them is a
driver whose truck overturned while
delivering water to the fire lines the
wildfires destroyed some 5700 homes and
businesses
Matea via al is in Santa Rosa where a
husband held his wife for hours in a
pool trying to keep her alive
Maria good morning good morning
search-and-rescue crews are going
through burnt-out homes just like this
they are looking for victims and they
are looking for hazardous material that
might make it difficult for people to
return home we spoke with one woman who
says her parents took refuge from the
wildfires in a swimming pool for several
hours only one of them made it out alive
it was escaper died Monica Barris and
her family were in her friend Santa Rosa
home enjoying an annual vacation when
they smelled smoke
and within a minute there were thirty
foot flames on both sides of the house
it was after midnight Monica's parents
Carmen and Armando followed her in a
convoy of cars the fire storm made
visibility so poor she couldn't see that
her parents car got stuck behind her
forcing the couple to flee on foot into
a nearby pool it was just a miracle that
my father survived it I wish my mom had
had the stamina to make it just a little
bit longer
Armando suffered second degree burns
holding on to his wife of 55 years in
the pool for at least five hours until
her lungs gave out she passed so
peacefully in his arms and he was so
pleased that it wasn't anything but
peace Carmen Barris is one of more than
40 confirmed deaths from Northern
California's wildfires
71 year-old Daniel Southern sent a text
message to his son who lost his mother
at the age of two just before the fires
broke out Leroy and Donna Halbert had
just celebrated their 50th wedding
anniversary at 14 KY Shepard was among
the wildfires youngest victims his
family members badly injured the search
continues for dozens of people still
missing maybe they ran out of the house
and they died in a neighbor's house so
so right now we're just trying to give a
real good
sweeping before before you allow the
general public back in there are still
more than a hundred people unaccounted
for and as crews go through all of this
rubble they are being extremely careful
about when and where they use cadaver
dogs to make sure they stay safe in this
process as well
Gayle very tough story thank you very
much Maria